a luta
não levo nada comigo da vida não tenho
nada é frágil minha jornada pois caminho
perigo à procura do abrigo eu vou
tentando viver às vezes e merecer
solitária e confuso
a vida é um parafuso só jesus pode
distorcer procura um destino chamado
felicidade que junto com a verdade
também desatino preferiu então ser
menino e na inocência viver fingindo não
perceber meu caminho tão difuso a vida
um parafuso
só jesus para distorcer ou plantando
todo dia a paixão no meu quintal
tentando espantar o mal com o sonho e
poesia cativando a alegria ea procura do
saber
desprezando sofrer pois descartei já não
uso a vida um parafuso
só jesus para distorcer quero no final
da vida teve um grande amor ter sentido
alguma dor de desamparo e guarida que
sabe minha ferida na morte se deus
quiser e quando a hora vier leve um
corpo em desuso a vida é um parafuso
só jesus pode esquecer né eu vou falar
pra vocês sobre minha vida vou falar
sobre como a poesia entrou na minha vida
como eu fiz da poesia administrada mas
principalmente como através da poesia eu
consegui mudar vidas mudar pessoas e na
simpatia na paraíba e dizem que toda a
cidade do interior tem um louco ou um
poeta impacto eu conheci um cara que era
as duas coisas e poeta e uma vez eu
estava andando na rua assim em meus 14
anos
ele chegou para mim e disse posso
escrever uma poesia pra você
eles podem escrever um soneto somente
cruz de souza é um pouco conhecia sobre
soneto muito menos preguiçoso mas quando
cheguei em casa comecei a procurar
alguns livros que falar sobre isso
encontrei um livro chamado profeta
gibran khalil gibran
não é um livro de poesia mas tem muita
poesia nas entrelinhas gibran né
com o tempo eu vim morar em pernambuco e
eu fui cursar faculdade fiz história e
dentro do curso de história encontra um
poeta
o pesquisador do cangaço que chama paulo
moura e diz porque tudo pega essas duas
poesias e transforma em literatura de
cordel
eu comecei a fazer alguns versos e meus
amigos que já estava estagiando como
professor começar a me chamar para fazer
a oficina de cordel nas escolas deles
com os alunos deles né então disposto
acho interessante é isso que eu quero
nessa época eu era representante
comercial trabalhava com acessórios de
carro e eu disse como é que eu vou viver
de poesia deixar uma coisa pra começar
outro como é que eu vou fazer
mas aí eu peguei um estágio para
professor de história e nas horas vagas
eu fazer essas oficinas de cordel e foi
dando certo
só que o trabalho que fazem nas escolas
era um trabalho mais da cultura
nordestina
só que eu percebi uma coisa que tem a
poesia a literatura de cordel ela pode
ser usada no contexto pedagógico
eu fiz um livro chamado educando e
cordel que é o livro é o nome também no
meu projeto e eu comecei a trabalhar nas
escolas esse livro no contexto
pedagógico falando de sílabas tônicas
divisão de seguros poetas métrica rima
tudo isso colocando os jovens né e
comecei a fazer esse trabalho nas
escolas
e foi ficando interessante só que aí eu
percebi que dentro das minhas poesias e
dos trabalhos que eu fazia
o jovem se interessavam mas também
começou a mudar o comportamento desses
jovens em sala de aula e no contexto
poeto claro né
eu comecei a perceber o que é que fazia
esses jovens mudar através de uma poesia
que é uma poesia simples do homem do
sertão foi quando eu vi uma poesia de
patativa do assaré chamada a morte de
nanã onde ele fala sobre a filha que
morreu na seca onde ele diz assim eu vou
contar uma história mas não sei como
comércio porque meu coração chora a dor
no meu peito cresce argumenta meu
sofrimento eu fico me lamento e me ama
de corrida pois é bem triste a sentença
de quem perdeu a inocência que mais amou
na vida eu tô velho acabrunhado mais
limpa desse chão fui o mais afortunado e
todos feriadão dentro de minha pobreza
eu tenho uma grande riqueza era minha
querida fia
porém morreu muito nova foi sacudida na
cova os seis anos do dia
a essa poesia é longa mas no final da
poesia e assim em uma noite de agosto
noite escura e celular
eu vi crescer meu desgosto eu vi que
recebeu penar
naquela noite a criança se achava sem
esperança e quando veio romper da lenda
e risonho aurora fartava bem poucas
horas
pra mim ela morrer na sua pequena boca
eu vi lá tremendo e numa aflição louca
ela também conhecendo que a vida estava
no fim foi regalando pra mim
os três saíam seu fez um esforço aiai é
de sabença papai fechou e morreu
nem quando escutei aquela poesia de
patativa eu disse é isso é isso que toca
às pessoas
a simplicidade do ano sertão com a
poesia e quando eu estava fazendo todas
essas mudanças na minha vida alguma
coisa aconteceu que talvez tenha sido a
inspiração né
por mais que a gente pensa que é ruim
mas foi a inspiração
minha mãe partiu e quando ela partiu
disse eu tenho que tomar agora uma
decisão na vida eu vou viver de poesia
nesse dia surge um verso que eu fiz pra
ela chamada se você voltar amanhã eu
queria dividir isso com vocês porque foi
nesse momento que começou minha
trajetória e eu falo como se fosse uma
criança do interior falando com a mãe
porque nós somos eternas crianças com as
nossas mães a aids assim manhã eu te
escrevo pois me bater a saudade
são palavras simples linha mais pura
verdade quando você foi embora
a partir da mesma hora um pedacinho de
mim bem triste eu fiquei me desculpe se
errei só apenas um menininho
se você volta amanhã é toda a manhã tem
beijo trago rosas lado mato e que enche
de desejo o desejo pra você ficar nunca
mais voltei largar vou grudar no seu
cangote e quando você me chamar no seu
lado eu vou estar diz que a senhora not
declaro minha mãe não vou mais a tr a
tomar banho no riacho nossa senhora
deixar vou me deitar bens e de roubar
fruta do vizinho juro não faz marcão e
quando consigo andar
prometo não vou saltar mas nunca tomam
se você adoecer e prepara um remédio
lavar os pratos almoço de manhã corta o
capim
dou comida pra galinha quando foi de
tardezinha se a senhora melhorar
boto rádio lá no quarto e carlos bicho
do mato
o da senhora rezar se você voltar amanhã
prometo me comportar quando não tiver
comida nunca mais vou chorar vou me
deitar para dormir pois assim não vou
sentir fome nenhuma fraqueza quando eu
crescer
nunca mais quero te ver e viver nessa
pobreza
quando eu crescer uma mãozinha você foi
pai que une nos deixou uma tristeza sem
fim
quero ver você velhinha assentada na
cozinha diz goiano feijão e quando em
casa chegar do trabalho vou te dar um
chega o coração manhã não quero mais
morar com minha madrinha
não tenho dormir eu quero a minha
caminha suas histórias escutar no teu
colo me deitar e ficar fazendo manha
quando meu lençol cair não quer nem me
engolir
deixe que a senhora apanha e pede papai
do céu para a senhora voltar
se eu levasse a mãe dele disse que não
ia gostar quero ver o teu sorriso se
quiser um improviso uma frase bem
bonitinha e vou pro céu te mostrar pois
aqui só vou ficar
se você voltar manhã e essa poesia eu
fiz pra ela e quando restava suas
poesias eu percebia que os jovens se
emocionavam com ela em 2015 mais ou
menos eu fui fazer um trabalho na escola
e eu encontrei um professor que é dj
nome de alessandro félix
ele fazia um trabalho de rap nas escolas
e eu percebi que alguns alunos de
comunidades tinham estereótipo poesia de
cordel e depois de matuto eo rapper pois
imaginava
então eu chamei sandra e diz vamos fazer
o seguinte é fazer um projeto pra gente
chamar esse jovem para as escolas é
papás oficinas ea gente fez um projeto
chamado rap cordel onde a gente
utilizava a poesia de cordel com a
musicalidade do rap e uma vez eu fui
convidado para uma palestra onde estava
gabriel pensador e gabriel ia fazer uma
palestra não me cantar e eu levei meus
alunos ea gente fez uma poesia para
cantar lá onde os meninos dizia assim
nos versos da poesia eu vou retirar o
véu do que chama o preconceito sobre o
rap com cordel foi juntando as duas
áreas estão fazendo meu papel
usando essa mistura vou falar
administrar
o que pensa no futuro dessa dura
caminhada das flores que vão plantar no
percurso da jornada ela tanto minha vida
chega parece contar seu humilde e
persistir para a riqueza alcançar ea
riqueza que procuro ou agora te falar
só quem veio da favela sabe que a
adrenalina tem nada não tem largar teu
espaço termina tem nomeado começa em
tudo que contamina mas também tem
família que cheguei para a luz tem
amizade sincera que também só te conduz
tem o foco na escola o pensamento de
jesus no final eles terminassem para
gabriel né
obrigado pensador pela sua trajetória
através do seu exemplo teremos também
vitória pois somos protagonistas de
nossa própria história somos
protagonistas de nossa própria história
eu disse está grande demais e professor
quem é educado aqui sabe né é grande
demais e um dos alunos chegou pra mim e
depois diz o professor
esse foi o momento mais feliz da minha
vida e depois eles começaram a
trajetória deles fazendo poesia fazendo
rap no ano de 2017 final de 2017 agora
para 2018 a secretaria de educação do
estado me chamou para fazer uma parceria
com elas com ela né ea parceria era
dentro de um projeto que é um projeto do
governo federal é remissão de pena pela
leitura como funciona isso
um detento e leu o livro e ele tem que
fazer um resumo resenha de acordo com a
escolaridade dele se obter nota 6
ele ganha sete dias a menos de pena aqui
em pernambuco nos outros estados é um
pouco menor
então a secretaria me chamou pra que eu
faça antes uma oficina de cordel com
eles para que através da poesia da
reflexão da filosofia eles possam
enxergar a leitura de outra forma
então estou dentro das unidades
prisionais trabalhando com reeducandos
onde do lado de fora a gente tem alguns
estereótipos e quando a gente chega lá a
gente percebe grandes poetas né fazendo
versos e uma coisa que me fez crescer
muito é que quando estou nas unidades
prisionais eu não posso julgar eu não
posso olhar para eles e saber o que foi
que eles fizeram mas eu quero sim saber
o que eles vão fazer quando saírem de lá
e apoio
e tem ajudado eu tenho percebido nos
versos que eles fazem
falando muito sobre liberdade é o tema
principal
mas existe uma coisa que está nas
entrelinhas é a questão do perdão perdão
por ter feito alguma coisa com alguém
por não ter sido perdoado mas
principalmente por ainda não terem se
perdoados
aí eu fiz um poesia chamada perdão onde
eu diga sim perdão não é esquecimento
das ofensas cometidas e saulo tudo feito
e tratando as feridas para que as
lembranças ruins não seja mais
percebidas perdão não é abraçar beijar
ofensor é se apegar com cristo e curando
a sua dor pra depois enfim curado
abraçar o ofensor perdão não é apagar o
algoz de sua vida ou levá lo para casa
dando pra ele guarda mas quem sabe orar
por ele até o dia da partida
o perdão é observar os pensamentos do
dia e se não tiver negativo muda toda
sintonia para que no céu cinzento surge
um sol de harmonia
o perdão é olhar a seca ver o que
machuco perceber quanto cresceu quando
se modificou que na janela da vida a
paisagem mudou o perdão r da vida é ser
nela um palhaço trocar o choro à raiva
pelo cheiro um abraço em vez de querer
jogar melhor apertar o laço
o perdão é se acolher é por dentro se
amar é seguir reconhecer fazer novo
caminhar quebrando elos correntes dos
grilhões libertar o perdão é perdoar
simples assim meu irmão foi o que jesus
mostrou lá na classificação que apesar
dos nossos atos dele tivemos o perdão e
quando ela recita poesia eu peço para
que cada um pegue uma estrofe que mais
me tocou e fala sobre essa poesia o que
mudou na vida deles e é isso é isso
minha caminhada é poesia né a cada passo
é fazer um novo né tentando mudar
algumas coisas erradas
lembrei de uma poesia de o vita do poeta
amazan da paraíba
vocês vão se identificar com essa coisa
o poeta amazan índice atingiu visita de
joão vicente
viúva de nicolau depois de um acidente
no dia de carnaval
o hospital foi levada e depois de
internada entrou em coma profundo
ficando meio apagada passando uma
temporada na sombra do outro mundo
porém os seus muito contente ficou pois
se encontrou com deus e o salvador e
falou você pode retornar lá pra terra e
ficará pôr em prática novos planos e
nada deve temer porque só ia morrer
daqui a 40 anos a coisa boa né juve tem
uma fé dessas criação do povo as pernas
cheias de vencimento larga de ouro o
narigão de tucanas urina ea banda canela
de bem-te-vi fazia alguma ginástica mas
nunca fez uma plástica com medo bisturi
porém depois que saiu do coma
tranquilamente por que deus lhe garantiu
quanto 40 anos pra festa né
chamou um cirurgião fez logo a relação
do que queria ajeitar personare
sobrancelha pescoço buchecha orelha nada
podia faltar fez uma lipoescultura de um
trato dos cabelo ficou com a estatura o
cordão modelo o bo siliconado bumbum
arrebitado pela fina reluzente recebeu
alta final na porta do hospital sofreu
um trágico acidente um acidente fatal
vejam só que o resultado na frente do
hospital tinha superado
foi isso que aconteceu juve tas bota
bateu foi vela preta caixão
mas quando chegou no céu procurou o pai
fiel pedindo explicação o intimidade
dela né
ela disse me responda pai amado me diga
por favor
conversamos mês passado na conversa o
senhor me garantiu ser segredo que não
morrer tão cedo mas no entanto eu morri
e deus responde seguro juvita desculpe
eu juro que não me reconheci meus amigos
para que deus nos reconheça nessa
caminhada para que a gente possa fazer a
caminhada bem feita não possa ser que o
poeta cheguei lá e deus mapa tema
decompõe professor e tudo fez a
caminhada bem feita
vamos fazer a caminhada porque às vezes
a gente diz assim ah eu não posso eu não
consigo né
eu sou tão pequeno eu não tenho recursos
para fazer
já imaginou se no começo de certo vai
trabalhar com poesia
e eu dissesse não dá para trabalhar com
poesia então lembrando que cada um de
vocês pode fazer a diferença né
o poeta petrúcio amorim grande poeta e
diz assim não sou profeta muito menos
visionário mas o diário desse mundo tá
na cara um viajante na boléia do destino
sou mais um fio da tesoura e da navalha
levando a vida tiro versos da cartola
chora viola nesse mundo sem amor
desigualdade rima com hipocrisia uma vez
nem poesia que console o cantador a
natureza na fumaça se mistura morre a
criatura e o planeta cento a dor o
desespero no olhar de uma criança a
humanidade fecha os olhos para não ver
televisão é fantasia violência aumenta o
crime cresce a fonte do poder foi
concedido deve lama barriga seca não dá
sono eu não sou dono do mundo mas tem
culpa porque sou filho do dono
[Música]
obrigado obrigado a encerrar pelo menos
um verso sozinho e repente né
o ted a inspiração como um verso do
repente
então muito sua vida faça a vida
diferente
o futuro não é mais como era antigamente
[Aplausos]